ROMAN NURIK: I think onboarding
is one of the hardest
things to design, right?
Those first 30 seconds of
using an app are critical.
If users get annoyed or confused
in those first 30 seconds
they're just going to
uninstall your app.
Then all that work
you spent designing
every single little
interaction to its perfection
in the rest of the app is just
going to kind of go to waste.
My name is Roman Nurik.
I'm a designer on the Firebase
team here at Google New York.
Today I want to show you
the onboarding experience
for this app called Notion.
It's an email app, and I
think the way it onboards
new users is done really well.
It's really interesting.
So let's take a look.
So I'm going to go ahead
and open up the app,
and the first thing it does
is it asks me for permission
to access my contacts,
which makes a lot of sense
for an email app.
So I'll go ahead and accept.
One thing it could do is maybe
ask for this a little bit later
in a slightly more contextual
way, but I think overall,
this is fine.
Next it's going to
ask me to sign in,
and the nice thing here is I
don't have to type anything.
I don't have to enter
an email and a password.
It's looked at the
stuff on my device
and it's let me just choose
something and move forward.
One thing I should say here
is that for an email app
this makes a lot of
sense, but most apps,
you should try to probably
avoid requiring sign
in or registration up front.
You probably want
to give the user
a sampling of your
content, a little bit
of a feel for your
app before asking
them to commit to your app.
The next thing it does
is it asks me to choose
a notification frequency.
This is really clear and
makes a lot of sense as well,
but one of the things
I might suggest here
is you could potentially
just show notifications,
and then in that
first notification
that a user receives, they could
choose their desired frequency.
I think this is fine, though.
This is very common to ask
about notifications up front,
so it's OK.
But this could be
potentially one way
to reduce the number of steps
in onboarding, which is really,
really good for conversions.
The next thing that
it does is it shows
me this conversational card.
It shows me my
email, but then it
says Notion needs a little bit
of time to understand my email.
I think this is great.
It's really friendly.
It's really engaging.
It makes it feel
like I'm talking
to a human, which really
makes this app approachable.
Now, once Notion
understands my email,
it's going to take me
through a tutorial that
teaches me about some of
the more advanced features.
And the first step
here is it shows
me the difference between
important and unimportant
emails.
I think one of the things that
could be a little better here
is there could be a slightly
less subtle visual distinction
between these.
It's a little unclear--
or less clear-- which
one's important,
which one's unimportant.
So either using some sort of
motion or showing it in context
might work a little better.
Now this next step is
really, really interesting.
Most tutorials have a
Next button in every step,
but here there's no Next button.
To proceed you have to
use this gesture to swipe.
I think this is kind
of a gutsy move.
It's really good to
kind of force people
to learn this key
interaction, and I
think this makes a lot of sense
because it's really important
that I learn this.
If I don't learn
this, I'm missing out
on a huge part of this app.
So I'll go ahead and
make that gesture,
and then it shows me the results
of having done that gesture.
So it kind of gives me
that sense of confidence
that this is what happens
after I take that action.
So this last bit here is I've
learned how to use Notion,
I'm scrolling through, and
you'll see this floating action
button that shows a number or
a count of unimportant e-mails
that Notion has found
for me to archive.
So once I press this, it selects
all those unimportant emails
and then I can take
action, archive or delete.
Now the cool thing is,
once I press archive,
it shows me a way to
make that even faster.
I think this is super,
super important.
It's taken this context of
I just performed an action,
and it's teaching me about
ways that I can speed that up
even more.
One of the notes
here is that I think
this uses a dialogue which
takes me out of my flow.
One of the things
that the app could do
is potentially show a bottom
sheet that isn't modal.
So that's how Notion
onboards new users.
I think it's really,
really delightful overall.
I think the fact
that I didn't have
to type anything in the
first couple of seconds,
I could just select an
existing email account
to sign in was excellent.
You definitely don't
want to lose users
just because you have these long
complicated forms to fill out.
Also, one thing that's
really important
is the language they use
was really friendly, casual,
informal.
And that kind of tone,
that kind of language
makes it much easier
for users to form
an emotional bond with your app,
which I think is really great.
And lastly, I think
that Notion was
really sensitive to context.
It almost felt like the
actions I was taking,
Notion was responding to really
well in the right moment.
So I think that overall,
it's a job really well done.
Definitely take a look at the
app if you get a chance to,
especially if you're
designing an onboarding
experience for your own app.
So that was my take on
Notion's onboarding experience.
If you have an app you want us
to take a look at, click here
to submit it, and
make sure to subscribe
to our channel for more
awesome design videos.